well i got an update on wilder farter if
you want to know about that will the
fart has been able to you know go
through life now without a regular job
because he can fart on command and i
mean deep
luscious farts that are just out of this
world he was born without a sphincter
and the doctors rebuilt his [ __ ] when
he was a baby
and somehow when they rebuilt his
[ __ ] they made it so that he can fart
on command but i don't mean like just
little toots i mean like these big
gigantic blasts
let me show you how good is his his
cameo messages are there's like him here
he is doing a birthday party
yeah yeah here you go
happy birthday too
happy birthday to the quality
happy birthday
dear oh
so he's making good money but the guy is
at a crossroads right now he is
considering walking away from farting to
become a stand-up comic and this is oh
my god
no offense i know the guy many years now
he's he's a terrific guy but he is not
funny
he has never made you laugh unless he's
farting farting is what this man was
made to do
actually he was man-made he wasn't even
born to do this he was created i'll show
you what he does best we had adam
carolee and he was the judge
on some kind of a farting thing
and uh will
farted for a 30 second long fart
oh
wow
wow please relax
wow 30 seconds
a once-in-a-lifetime talent and what's
so crazy with his farting is like you
think he's out of juice and then all of
a sudden it gets better
yeah and it goes forever now this is
what drives me crazy will says he's
ready to evolve he wants to quote drift
away from farting
and focus on stand-up comedy
and that drives me crazy i mean you've
you've already
hit the lottery in terms of show
business so
you made a name for yourself already
what's the matter with you your name's
will the fighter will performed his
comedy for us over zoom
all these
caravans and immigrants
walk into the southern border they go
a good rule of thumb if you're walking
to the country chances are we don't want
you here fly on a private jet or drive a
mercedes the truckload of cash to pay
your taxes it will make room for you but
we already have enough poor people born
here that we're stuck with i told them
to fart after every joke like a rim shot
like the old comedians used to do you
know
like you know like
which gets back to our point say nothing
and just fart